thank you all for coming so my name is
Doris patina I'm the director of
consulting at Quon site who we're
sponsoring the conference and who here
is from astronomy anyone oh come on
there's gotta be someone yeah your
physics I know my guys so a little wide
because most of the people in data
science seem to end up coming from
somewhere else and I'm not an astronomer
I basically know stars of big balls of
hydrogen kind of you know things like
that this is a talk which is partly
based on last Ronna me and Tim Morton
who is at university South California
previously at Princeton he's the subject
matter expert this is kind of a good
example of scientists commercial company
and the open source community working
together to build something which i
think is pretty cool and so I had not
heard of the LSST before this project
but it is a telescope being built in
Chile that's going to go online in 2022
that's what the construction currently
looks like it's not fully complete the
mirror and other stuff has been
constructed I think it's I think it's
already being the mirrors already been
shipped to Chile and they're doing
integrate you know that this website is
pretty cool I'm going to show a few more
pictures it's from my understanding so
the bottom picture is actually the size
of the mirror and it's it's the largest
telescope mirror ever built and it is
going to survey the night entire night
sky every couple of days for ten years
like depending on cloud cover and stuff
expected to generate 15 terabytes of
data a night 60 to 100 petabytes over
the 10-year period okay when when
business people keep talking about big
data they haven't really talked to
astronomers or you know my original
background is computational fluid
dynamics fluid dynamics hurricane
modeling all that kind of stuff
we deal with datasets which is a lot
bigger than you know most people who
talk about Hadoop and all that kind of
stuff
so what's the problem okay this is a lot
of data okay
and so that they've actually have a
whole team so this is not gonna actually
start be turned on till 2022 but there's
a whole team of multiple scientists and
engineers and stuff there's a whole
corporation behind this and they're
building the data there's a whole team
building a data pipeline because this
isn't you know Chile the data has to
come back to the u.s. be stored
somewhere transformed cleaned everything
archived and so there's a whole group
building a really complex data pipeline
guess how they evaluate whether the
pipeline is working correctly any any
guesses who who's the C I'm gonna put
the next little bit up I'm gonna talk
about a little because we've all done
this this is how they evaluate the data
pipeline they got a folder full of
static plots and someone's kind of
flipping through them so that one looks
bad let's go let's go back and rerun you
know and I'm joking about this a little
because I've done this and I'm not
hitting on math what Lib because my
problem was my gateway drug that pulled
me into Python in 2008 because I was
using MATLAB and I found my prod lib and
everything was lovely so I love my
problem it's a great tool for product
yeah like publication quality print
graphics and things like that it's not a
great tool for this problem
so Tim Tim kind of talked with us and
we're like okay we would we've got a
better way of doing this now and the the
way we're doing this now isn't something
that was possible even a couple of years
ago and what is what is the LSST deep
they want an open source stack there
they're a you know scientific
engineering group they want to be able
to mess with this stuff they don't want
something prepackaged that they can't
change
it's got to be interactive because
they're trying to understand why things
are broken you know in the data pipeline
and stuff like that it's got a handle
large data sets I mean it has to handle
RJ says if they can only see a tiny
piece of their data it's useless for
evaluating their system and it's a
science organization they cannot afford
to have an outside organization maintain
their staff they have to be able to
tweak it and there's two parts of this
and this is a little picture I put below
if you go to the hall of his webpage
because some of the technology we were
using come from Holloway's there's a
really nice example of the New York taxi
data set and visualizing it in the
browser and kind of playing around with
it and stuff and so that's what we
usually do we play scientists engines we
play around stuff build plots things
like that have you there's another
website I've called this is hubcap I
kind of found it a couple of years ago
so really slick interface to explore the
same New York taxicab data face and it
looks amazing and it works really well
it's great but it's a custom coded app
built by a team of JavaScript developers
and when you know exactly what you want
you can throw resources at building in
do you have a question
no so so they're building a so they have
raw sensors that collect the actual data
in different wavelengths and it goes
through a pipeline of processing steps
before they have the datasets that the
scientists are going to use so they're
building that data pipeline and it's an
automated pipeline but they need to know
mmm yes so one of one of the things with
the dashboard I'm showing you which
isn't done yet is they want to have so
they've got some metrics on the things
and they want to have some pass fails on
those metrics and when the metrics fail
they want to explore the data on it so
the dashboard is meant to show those
which metrics are failed so they can
explore them so yeah this psych so the
thing the the dashboard on the you're
right when you know what you need
building a really polished app for that
is easy you throw money at it you throw
developers at it the problem is you
often don't know what you need and the
people who have the domain expertise to
build an experiment and try and work out
what you need they can do this they
can't write JavaScript they don't want
to write JavaScript I've been in
organizations where going from this to
that is a six month to one year process
with a separate team where you're trying
to educate the JavaScript people what
the science my actually long this is a
this is an anecdote from a long time ago
I was working with a group of web
developers and we were building a
website to show all the Hurricanes that
ever hit Texas and this was back like
jQuery days like 10 years ago
and they said they could only display
200 hurricanes at a time I'm like ok
that that's fine we'll work around it
well they decided to every time you
refresh a play page it would show you a
random 200 hurricanes not the
alphabetical not the year and I was like
why would you think that would but for
them it was a it was a computer science
problem it wasn't how will people use
this and so that's the problem you have
you have to throw something over the
wall and I call it the scaling problem
this happens in a lot of different areas
you know conceptual model high fidelity
physics Python to JavaScript Java you
have when you have to change your tool
set or toolkit as you scale you have
impotence you have problems and often
you hit a cliff so yes I can do my stuff
in a jupiter notebook i can do it in one
on one computer
oh my datasets too big to fit in memory
I need to go write everything in MPI or
I need it you know so so it's this kind
of thing where your experimentation and
your place where you experiment and the
place where you do things that scale are
completely different and have that have
different toolkits different skill sets
different people and that slows down
innovation and it slows down your
ability to communicate data and
communicate results so we built this on
an open stack and I'm gonna not go into
detail about this just kind of give you
the pieces tasks you've heard a couple
of talks about desk task let's scale to
bigger and bigger data sets while still
being in a pandas numpy like interface
so it feels the same even though you're
using bigger data sets Hall of views
lets you really easily build interactive
linked plots where what you're doing one
plot is connected to another one and you
can explore and you can search data
shader is my favorite thing ever
I met Jim bednar a couple years ago and
he presented a saipan data shader data
shader lets you now what it essentially
does is if you have a really massive
data set let's say it has a billion
points if you are looking at it on a
browser window and you push the billion
points to the browser window you will
crash your browser but you can actually
only physically see 800 pixels by 800
pixels or whatever so data shader
intelligently rasterizes your code I
mean your your data
so all that you're sending to the
browser is one image and as you zoom and
you pan and you do everything it
we rasterizes it so it doesn't really
matter what the size of your data is you
can always interactively manipulate it
in a browser interface and then this is
all really good for experimentation and
panel now lets you build the app or the
dashboard that you want to deploy to
your users we want a prototype in
Jupiter and we're kind of experimenting
with deploying with Jupiter hub on that
cluster and that's still kind of
happening but this stack allows
scientists and engineers to experiment
push things along but also the deploy
apps at a very well a good scale it may
not be as polished of a end product as
you know a five man JavaScript team
writing everything in d3 over six months
but I guarantee you you can you can
iterate much faster and if you do come
out with oh this is this is the exact
analysis we want then it may be worth
rewriting it directly in another stack
but this lets you experiment and I'm the
rest of my time will be a live demo with
code that is not completely stable so we
will see how this goes yeah so so
there's two pieces as well there's a
bunch of data engineering and all this
codes online you know shared later but
I'm just importing we we wrote a little
module called LSST dashboard it's not
that much code there's there's one data
set our py file it handles getting the
data out of their system
and there's a GUI dot py that implements
the dashboard and it I think it's maybe
like 150 lines it's not a lot of code
and okay the one fun thing where I asked
when we started this project I asked him
okay I need a small test data set just
we can experiment and he gave me half a
terabyte so this is 10% of that data
just because if I need the full data set
I need to be on that cluster and I
didn't know how Wi-Fi was here so I'm
using 10% of the test data set right now
and so and I've got it locally instead
of on the cluster so I'm just reading it
in this is this is just a little class
that reads it in connects the data it
kind of does some reformatting pulling
in different data sets and right now I'm
reading one tract so they divide the sky
into tracts which is like one piece of
the sky like you know and the test
dataset is three tracks I think I'd have
to talk to Tim I think it's like several
hundred tracks is the entire sky you
know and we have these filters these are
from what I understand these are
different wavelengths of the light and
they've got different sensors for the
different wavelengths and for each
wavelength oh and they have this concept
called explaining visit I mean there's a
whole thing of me understanding the
domain of this data so what did every
every time the telescope tracks a
particular area that's a visit to that
area and then they a great multiple
visits into a compiled data set call it
tracked so and for each of that they
have about 300 variables and these ten
or so variables are metrics that talk
about the data quality and I have no
idea what any of these words mean if
you're from astrophysics it might make
sense to you this is what they want to
look at to decide whether the data
pipelines is good or bad and they want
to write some kind of conditions if this
one varies by a certain you know
standard deviation then mark this you
know this metric failed or something
like that now if I pull out one of them
I'm gonna pull out this HS g'quan PSF
mag diff mm mag which I have no idea
what it is this is a das data frame so
it took about a second to pull that out
if you see there is actually no data
here all it says is there's three
partitions so and this is a small day so
there's only three partitions
so it's just a placeholder with kind of
pointers to where the data is in some
sense and if I do a here I'm going to do
a DF not compute and it's going to kind
of aggregate everything and give you
back a panda's data frame this worked
right now and if you see at the end
you've got some data and then at the end
it with that they ran a classifier on it
so it tells if it's a galaxy or you know
a star or something they didn't
recognize if I did this DF compute on
the actual data set I crashed my browser
or my Jupiter because you know half a
terabyte browsers do the math you know
but usually what happens is and you know
usually in the system you wouldn't do a
DF compute you just ask will let you
lazily kind of pile things on so you
know that you see the length of this
this is 1.3 million 1.4 million rows and
you know I do a filter and some stuff
and I get down to a smaller thing so
you'd probably run some filters and so
I'm not yeah there's nothing there so
the point I'm making like this I'm going
to take some of those data sets and you
know I've got a data set and a filtered
data set and I'm just going to use panel
to say I want a column and two rows with
the data and the filter data and now I
have a nice little plot which shows data
a filtered data something else so this
RA and Dec that is right a clenching and
declination so that's kind of a
coordinate system of where you are
longitude and latitude and this is some
metric here so the point is these are
the kind of plots scientists will make
and are comfortable making in joopa
notebooks you know we're using some
fancy tools but it's not anything too
difficult for someone who's reasonably
good at scripting and python to learn
now we've got I told you we have a but
we have about
150 lines of code maybe 200 lines of
code in this GUI py and from I'm gonna
import that and now I can say dashboard
rendered our show and it launches our
full app I'm actually in the clothes I
just wanted to show you could launch it
from Jupiter but I'm gonna run it
another way because we also want to be
able to do this as a deployed website so
let me close this and restart this so we
have this panel serve command which
basically takes your entire application
you've built and just serves it as a
standalone web site and so that's you
know and right now it's running
localhost but we could run it and action
on an actual as an actual website and go
and let me get the folder name okay so
if I was running this on the actual
cluster the path I give there would
actually communicate where they have a
software called Butler that works out
where this data is on their archive
system and returns the you know the data
sets to you but right now I'm just
giving it a folder on my local directory
and it's gonna read that data in and
then it's going to populate what's
available over here and so that's what's
available and I'm going to just pick
something and let's see I will pick this
and so this is one of the filters and
you can see it or I can turn it off let
me go here and pick this
okay so this is some data and this is as
we saw earlier about a million and a
half points if this is one tenth day
this also works on the full test data
set which is ten times larger than this
but you know now I've got all my
interactivity I can zoom around it read
rasterizes as I'm zooming and panning so
you know if i zoom out it will work out
the correct scale to use and what colors
map to use there and this is I can
inspect a particular area and I can look
at that and I say okay oh this is
actually a star what about this one well
this is a galaxy you know you can kind
of inspect it you can and let's add
another one let's let's basically say
let's do this one cron again I don't
know what any of these actual metrics
mean I'm not an astrophysicist but now
one of the big things they wanted to do
is they say oh there's something
interesting happening over here okay
what does the other metric look like and
so these are tied together and tying
them together is very simple it's just
like one line of things thing I want
these tied together okay that's great I
want to look at it in a different view
so we got a detailed view and here we
have kind of these are the the top is
the individual vertices the individual
visits that this data comes from and
this is like a mean of it eventually
phase two they want to be able to click
on this point and open up the actual
entire data set that comes from that
point which we don't have implemented
yet these are all linked plots so if I
move something if I move this the one
there of course there's not going to
work now so if I move this the one below
moves too and then they want to know so
this is a metric this is the Gaussian
magged if for the entire star map and
they want to be able to say okay
actually I'm only interested in this
little area of the star
where do those points occur in this
metric and yeah okay I'm having problems
with my mouse you know what let me check
something yep I crashed something yeah
let me see if I can redo that as I said
this is not fully stable code yet but
it's getting there
okay let me get one of these and switch
over to the detail view okay so if I use
this selection and I select a portion
here the portion the portion of the
starmap I selected there is now what is
being shown in this plot then let's go
back to the sky view these are all this
data is linked so I cannot so they've
got these metric filters which are true
or false so I can say QA bad and I think
QA bad
true means this was it was a bad point
and so if I do QA by true I can add that
filter it will get rid of the data where
the QA flag was bad and so I can stack
these filters you can say this one oops
this one is false you know so now I'm
interactively exploring my data adding
filters to it and and and it's all
dynamic one last thing I'll show and
then you can remove the filters you know
I'm going to remove this one and if you
had five or six diagnosis you know five
five six metrics open these filters will
be applied to all of them
let's see remove and this is the one
that actually we wish we showed this
that they had a user's meeting we kind
of showed a demo of this or we were
going to and the folks of Princeton
basically said can you do this and one
like we haven't tried it but we can just
throw it in and see if it works
but they took they had these two metrics
and they said can we have a arbitrary
query that we run on the data okay let's
try it and see if it works and what was
the other one was this one
if they said if no one is think flux and
this is for power users if they wanted
to say this metric divided by this other
metric like is greater than 100 and this
is just passed into the pandas door
filter expression and if you run the
query expression then it should filter
out the things that meet that and and
they kind of said doing this one thing
the you know this flux by the flux are
greater than 100 actually takes them a
lot of time you know because they have
to go back and find the data and they
have to you know work out which one to
use so but so you know that's a nice
functionality there's some a few rough
cases here and there which we have to
still fix we can do about a half
terabyte a terabyte pretty well we need
to scale it bigger because right now
we're using tasks on one end of the
thing we're not using it on the other
end but the thing is this frameworks now
there a lot of the features like we
learned a lot through this process we've
got there's some new templating stuff
which is going back into panel and the
next version of panel is going to have
some default templates one of them which
is based on this the getting it set up
the first time was a little bit
complicated because we had to understand
all how all the pieces work together but
if the engineers or scientists want to
throw in a new plot want to change the
way these plots work it's very easy for
them to do that now you know there's
still some data engineering questions on
how we've grown really big data sets but
this enables continued innovation
whereas if we built a custom application
using Java Script d3 every all the
latest JavaScript tools we'd have an
amazingly slick app and some of the kind
of things which we're a little clunky
here might not be there but they would
have no way to move it forward without
paying someone else to do it and so
that's a large part of the motivation on
this and I'm gonna end with
two things I mean so you know I'll take
questions but I want to really shout out
to the open source community because the
hollow halt of esteem there's you know I
think John Luke is here and you know one
of his other Philip he helped us because
we we kind of stressed panel and
stressed hall of use with data sizes and
features that this is one of the more
complicated apps production apps built
on panel and so we found bugs and he
fixed them amazingly so this was and you
know and Brendan's at the back as well
he wrote a lot of the I did a lot of the
backend data stuff Brendan did a lot of
the front-end panels and other all of
you stuff but this really was domain
expertise and plotting expertise from
Tim because I do not know how to detect
whether something is a galaxy or star
you know that whole algorithms Tim's you
know we were paid as Quon site to try
and work out all the different pieces
and the open source community really
helped us where we found things and we
needed we were able to fix some bugs
they were able to fix some bugs but
finally we have something that the LSST
should be able to take forward and use
on their data and I'm pretty excited
like you know ten years of like surveys
on the night sky that I think the folks
are gonna learn a lot from that so that
it's the overall this is one of those
projects where it was fun from a
technical point of view but it's also
fun you're like oh we're working with
the LSST telescope that's that's also a
fun part so I've got some links here the
all the code for this is on github it's
not perfect there are like you can see
where we we have put hacks in that we
haven't fixed
I have two publicly available data all
the data is actually going to be
hopefully available it's just huge so I
have two data sets you can use with the
dashboard one is a 1% data set which is
about seven gig no I think I have one
person I have a 1 percent and 10 percent
data set and they're like 5 gig and 20
gig or something
the whole the whole test dataset it's
about 770 gig or something so I haven't
put that online yet so if you want to
play with this try it out it's a little
buggy you can hit corner cases but you
can always email me also just to plug
Quan site if you need to do something
like this and want our help we're happy
to help too and we'll do it in a way
where you can take over so I'm also
happy to take questions now thanks
[Applause]
right now I think all the plots are data
shaded the one caveat is in some of them
so you ideally we should be using tasks
directly with data shaded plots but
because we kind of had some time crunch
issues in some places we did a dot
compute before giving the plot to Paulo
view slash data shader so because of
that we're kind of on we have an upper
limit on right now certain data sets
have to fit in memory to work but that's
an easy fix we just haven't got to it
but yes they're pretty much they all
data shaded so panel supports plotly
plots in this particular project I don't
see any need to the last time I had to
work on something the main thing that
plotly had which I couldn't find in hall
of use this was like two years ago or
something was 3d plots but then
afterwards someone built a vtk j/s
plugin for panel so I did the 3d plots
with vtk Jas so you can if there's a
plot Lee plot that you really want panel
can integrate that and so you can
actually have a plot of a plot and a map
plot lib and you know different things
in the same dashboard very easily right
now all of youse does everything we need
for this project so in this project not
really yeah
any other questions
okay so I'll be around for a little
longer and you know the codes up and
feel free to email me thank you
[Applause]